tout d'abord permettez-moi de revenir
sur sur quelque chose c'est quand même
important pour moi de dire pourquoi
est-ce que j'ai décidé de venir ce soir
déjà pour exercer mon droit de réponse
qui est
fondamental dans cette dans cette
histoire puisque j'ai été gravement
diffamé dans votre émission et par
signer Wana donc c'est important de
commencer par ça
alors vous habitez le même quartier pas
du tout pas du tout pas du tout il
n'habite pas dans le square
de sa clinique il travaille dans ce
square
il travaille uniquement dans ce square
et moi j'habite ici depuis pratiquement
deux ans vous le croisiez souvent ou pas
de temps en temps on se croise on se
croise mais on ne se connaît pas il
travaille ici il voilà il je le vois
sortir je le vois rentrer mais ce n'est
pas notre ami on n'est jamais allé à sa
clinique on n'a jamais dîné déjeuner
chez lui ce n'est pas notre ami c'est
quand même important de se souligner
vous dites notre ami parce que vous
parlez de votre conjoint qui n'est pas
ce n'est pas l'ami de notre famille on
est on ne le connaît pas ce monsieur qui
a dit qu'il connaissait votre conjoint
mais en fait pas tant que pas plus que
ça d'après vous non pas du tout pas du
tout
il travaille c'est important de le
redire s'il n'est Ohana n'habite pas
dans le square il travaille dans le
square alors c'est donc lundi dernier
que tous ces déroulé si néo-ana nous
parle d'une terrible agression et vous
vous avez votre version qui est
différente nous avons des vidéos que
vous nous avez ramené on va revenir sur
ce qui s'est passé minute par minute du
début à la fin de cette affaire avec les
caméras de vidéos surveillance il n'y a
pas de son vous allez voir mais vous
allez voir les les caméras lundi vous
arrivez en voiture dans votre quartier
et pour vous vous allez vous garer
si noana affirme que vous pétaradier
autour de du square et en bas de sa
clinique donc on va voir les images vous
donc vous arrivez voilà
d'accord on vous voit voilà donc là vous
vous garez
on voit les caméras de surveillance
c'était vous venez de passer vous venez
juste vous garer parce que vous aviez
fait voir avant pas du tout là j'arrive
toujours je me gare d'accord et je suis
c'est important aussi de le dire je le
soir même c'est halloween c'est
l'anniversaire de ma cousine oui avec
des fleurs et je rentrais chez moi
justement pour me préparer et sortir
pour vous à aucun moment il y a une
nuisance sonore pas du tout et on le
voit bien comme comme le montre la vidéo
je suis en train de me garer vous
rentrez chez vous et comme vous le voyez
le square il est petit donc je suis je
roule au pas je roule au pas à aucun
moment j'accélère je me gare je me gare
tranquillement et
puis
avec aucune nuisance sonore à ce moment
là je ne fais que me garer je rentre à
la maison pour continuer de me préparer
et puis sortir j'ai jamais fait des
tours avant avec avec votre voiture et
votre tour cette voiture je l'ai depuis
à peu près un an
à aucun moment on nous a dit que cette
voiture faisait du bruit
à aucun moment alors c'est là que tout
commence c'est sinon Anna qui va
immédiatement aller vers vous ce que
vous dites quand vous coupez le moteur
il va il va venir vous voir et comme il
m'a dit va essayer de vous parler à
votre portière c'est ce qu'on voit sur
les images mais qu'est-ce que vous êtes
alors voilà
d'accord donc là
je suis déjà à l'extérieur mais pourquoi
et donc là je ne sais pas est-ce qu'il
vous dit là
vous voulez vraiment entendre ce qu'il
m'a dit on aimerait bien savoir oui en
tout cas ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que à ce moment précis je ne suis plus
dans la voiture je ne suis plus dans la
voiture en fait je ne comprends pas je
ne comprends pas la scène est de rentrer
dans la voiture pour je vous dis encore
une fois je ne comprends pas son
attitude à ce moment-là je me demande
pourquoi est-ce qu'il vient c'est pas
des places attribuées puisque les
mêmes là je suis garé à ma place il y a
deux places nous avons deux places de
parking et les deux places sont à nous
donc je suis garé à ma place derrière
c'est mon frère qui sort de la voiture
et donc à ce moment précis je ne sais
pas pourquoi est-ce qu'il vient ouvrir
la portière le moteur ne tourne pas je
suis alex je suis déjà dehors je suis à
l'extérieur je suis à l'extérieur
attendez c'est important de dire
je suis je suis à l'extérieur de la
voiture
comme vous allez le voir mon frère va
fermer le véhicule et l'alarme va être
enclenchée sur le tableau de bord on va
voir la lumière et vous allez le voir
donc le véhicule est fermé comme vous le
savez quand le véhicule il est fermé que
l'alarme a été mise le moteur ne peut
pas tourner le moteur ne peut pas
tourner alors
à ce moment-là
je me demande mais qu'est-ce qui lui
arrive pourquoi est-ce qu'il vient ce
monsieur pourquoi est-ce qu'il vient de
parler qu'est-ce qui lui arrive je me
gare je suis dans une optique de rentrer
chez moi d'aller me préparer et de
rejoindre mes amis pour une soirée je ne
comprends pas pourquoi il m'interpelle
c'est quoi l'échange là vous vous dites
quoi
à ce moment précis il a des propos très
durs sur quoi sur moi tout simplement il
me traite attendez Cyril il me traite de
sale noir de salle négresse on va vous
faire sortir du square vous n'avez pas
votre place au square vous n'avez pas
votre place au square et je vais crever
vos pneus à ce moment précis donc c'est
ce qui vous dit là direct
vous allez vous allez voir la scène qui
suit à ce moment précis
je précise que Monsieur J'ai demandé
pardon excusez-moi j'ai demandé à ne pas
avoir des changes
sans en parler pas de problème il m'a
précisé ne pas avoir tenu de propos
racistes et m'a dit que sa vie était des
dialogagement humanitaire en Afrique
noire partout donc il a eu la Légion
d'honneur pour ça donc il dément les
propos racistes très bien comme il a pu
témoigner sur votre plateau en disant
que à peine sorti de la voiture je
l'avais tout de suite rouet de coups et
cracher dessus à ce moment précis est-ce
que vous voyez que je lui crache dessus
est-ce que vous voyez que j'ai une
attitude agressive est-ce que vous voyez
que ce monsieur ciné Ohana et par terre
et roué de coups par mois pardon non à
aucun moment je suis agressive je ne
comprends pas pourquoi il
cherche à ouvrir ma voiture je ne
comprends pas en fait pourquoi ce
monsieur il est là et qu'est-ce qu'il me
veut tout simplement que je ne comprends
pas
je suis choquée quand il me quand il
m'agresse verbalement il a une il a déjà
une attitude il a une attitude anormale
verbalement physiquement je ne comprends
pas pourquoi est-ce qu'il pourquoi
est-ce qu'il m'interpelle je demande à
mon frère de de fermer la voiture et je
rentre je suis dans une démarche de
rentrer chez moi alors
que les choses vont s'envenimer allez
très loin regardez ce qu'on nous avait
amené les caméras de surveillance
c'est lui là à aucun moment j'ai une
attitude agressive à aucun moment au
contraire je dis à Brandon de fermer le
portail qu'on rentre à la maison il
pousse sa secrétaire à plusieurs
reprises elle essaie de le contrôler de
le maîtriser il force le passage de chez
moi il veut en découdre avec moi il veut
rentrer
à plusieurs reprises je leur demande de
quitter de quitter notre domicile on est
à l'intérieur de chez moi on n'est pas
dans la rue on est dans notre cours on
est à l'intérieur de ma maison
à plusieurs reprises on peut voir mon
doigt lever lui demandant de quitter de
quitter notre domicile
alors
je n'ai pas eu une attitude agressive je
n'ai pas eu une attitude agressive alors
on regarde vous avez ramené d'autres
vidéos on voit l'assistante de ciné qui
en plus lui aurait donné un coup
malencontreusement l'assistant beaucoup
de pouvoir elle lui a donné un coup de
coude
je ne suis pas médecin je peux juste je
peux juste vous dire que je n'ai pas
cassé le nez de Sidney Ohana et que ce
geste de son assistante aurait pu aurait
pu et à certainement casser son nez en
tout cas ce n'est pas moi c'est pas moi
mélodie juste on voit vous nous avez les
amis les images
pourquoi c'est neoana serait mieux sur
le plateau et auraitmenti c'est
incroyable parce que pourquoi il est
aussi énervé au départ c'est ça qu'on se
dit parce qu'on le voit arriver vers
votre voiture on se dit c'est bien passé
quelque chose il s'est passé quoi rien
rien Sidney Ohana a menti sur tout
absolument et il a eu une tribune ici
pour fixer son mensonge comme une vérité
du début c'est pour ça qu'on a vu de
version du début du début à la fin s'il
n'est Ohana a menti comme vous l'avez vu
vous l'avez vu sur les sur les vidéos
j'arrive je me gare je le repousse je
lui dis de rentrer chez lui que je
n'avais rien à lui dire que si
mélodie je vais vous dire je vais vous
dire sur quoi il a menti on le voit
clairement pour reprendre ses propos il
dit qu'il était en salle d'opération et
qu'il sortait en blouse d'opération il
est en tenue civile que je suis à peine
sorti de ma voiture que je lui ai
cracher dessus et rouer de coup
Sidney Ohana et son assistante qu'il a
fait un malaise qu'il était tombé par
terre à aucun moment sur ma vidéo on
voit ce monsieur par terre tombé par
terre en malaise il est debout il est il
est prêt en découdre avec moi il a une
attitude qui n'est pas normale une
attitude totalement agressive
je je ne répondrai pas ici vous n'avez
pas lui répondre il dit je refuse
absolument son attaque pour propos
racisme dont elle ne fournit aucune
preuve sur les auditions
vous l'avez annoncé ici je ne pouvais
pas faire valoir mon droit de réponse
puisque j'étais en garde à vue
je n'aime pas
je n'avais pas mon téléphone je n'avais
pas monté téléphone j'étais en garde à
vue oui
les garde à vue mais après il y a une
concentration de 9h pour chaque c'est
important de revenir sur quoi il a menti
pardonnez-moi je tiens vraiment à
continuer et à ce que les gens
comprennent sur quoi il a menti dites
nous ok il a dit que je que je lui ai
craché dessus que je l'ai roué de de
coup que il a fait état de de ma vie
privée en disant que je venais qu'on
venait de m'offrir un iPhone 14
déjà j'ai un iphone 13 pour la petite
précision et que
qu'est-ce qu'il a dit d'autre que je
voilà
vous l'aviez frappé voilà que j'ai eu
des que je ah oui que je l'avais menacé
de mort à plusieurs reprises à plus et
que j'avais un couteau voilà et que
j'avais un couteau à peine sorti de la
voiture que j'avais un couteau et je
reprends ces mots que je voulais le
planter je voulais le planter ce sont
les mots de cinéo Anna a aucun moment à
aucun moment je n'ai eu une attitude
agressive j'ai voulu me défendre avec
une autre voiture
j'ai voulu me défendre est-ce que vous
avez déjà eu un problème avec une autre
voisine c'est ce qu'il avait dit ici
aussi
est-ce que j'ai eu un problème avec une
autre façon
dans la journée j'ai eu alors je vais
vous raconter la scène puisque la scène
elle est très simple elle est très
simple je rentre de week-end ok c'est
Halloween je vais récupérer mes affaires
dans la voiture cette voisine en
l'occurrence elle est considérée
d'après ce qui se dit dans le soir comme
la petite amie de Sydney Ohana ce n'est
pas mon problème mais je vous raconte ce
que c'est ce qui se dit ce qui
portait plainte madame il faut quand
même le préciser ce qui se dit sur ce
qui se dit dans le dans le square cette
dame ok elle interpelle le chauffeur
pour lui dire les nuisances sonores sont
insupportables on n'en peut plus
j'entends cette dame se plaindre à aucun
moment je me dirige vers elle pour lui
répondre je continue ma vie je récupère
ce que j'ai à récupérer dans ma voiture
et à ce moment là son chien vient zapper
auprès de moi et je fais un signe avec
mon mon comment dirais-je ma jambe pour
pour l'éloigner sans même le toucher et
cette femme court vers moi le point levé
me menaçant qu'elle allait également
en découdre avec moi donc on a votre
version des deux histoires mélodies
est-ce que vous avez quelque chose à
ajouter ce soir
j'ai été gravement diffamé
ici et Sidney Ohana m'a fait beaucoup de
tort m'a fait énormément de Thor ils ont
menti du début jusqu'à la fin en disant
que j'avais été viré de ses news tout
ceci est faux tout ceci est faux je n'ai
jamais été viré au sein de ma rédaction
j'entretenais des relations tout à fait
normal avec mes collègues d'ailleurs
j'ai reçu énormément de messages de
soutien dans ce sens-là je suis partie
de la rédaction de ces news puisque
j'avais un autre projet professionnel et
je tiens également à dire que je suis
toujours journaliste et que j'exerce
toujours